hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamra Jeff's ah
and tonight I went and saw the second
Halloween the sequel to Halloween no not
that one
technically it's the eleventh but it's
the sequel this video is going to be
full of spoilers because I had a great
time and I want to talk about it the
film is about Laurie Strode and Michael
Myers being reunited after he is about
to be transferred to another prison he
escapes and then he comes after her she
toys the line of mentally insane and
just super badass and like this slasher
version of Rambo I've not seen Rambo but
what I imagine to be Rambo there's one
scene it's in the trailer yelling at
these kids to get out of here and she's
got a gun it's it's amazing it's very
effective
hell yeah Jamie Lee Curtis walking down
a street great crazy frizzy hair yelling
at kids is a big mood big 20:18 mood but
she's not wrong
she's like definitely right and knows
what she's doing and has been preparing
for this with this kind of film you
expect the scares that you get and the
best I can usually hope for is a lot of
anxiety world-building an anxiety
character building which I love I just
want to be filled with dread you know
what I mean every day all the time 24/7
I super appreciated the anxiety this
movie especially in the last scene that
takes place in her house
I think the fighting between her and
Michael in the end is really effective
too because it feels very real it feels
like you know she's like biting him or
like pressing in his eyes or like you
know doing things that aren't I would
say choreographed less choreographed
more just like a frantic fighting I was
talking with my friend I went to see the
movie with and he was like yeah so I
guess I think it's little h2o maybe the
eighth the seventh film I haven't seen
and apparently like the fighting is
really awesome with Jamie Lee
but it was like pretty choreographed
less like raw and wilds and this one was
also Adam gave me this says you can't
kill the boogeyman and it's awesome you
guys should check him out on Instagram
Adams art box amazing on the whole the
acting is incredible this side
characters are especially well built
very interesting the trap stick guy you
know and so he's not so great then you
get dancer boy then you you get the kid
who she the one girl babysits oh such
good side characters with a script
that's really funny but still pretty
grounded and believable a lot of this
movie was believable I would say outside
of a few of the kills which are all
awesome even if they're not believable
they are so great I wrote down a full
page in my notes of just amazing kills
you get the chief moment which we all
saw on the trailer how did he have time
to pluck out every tooth from this gas
station employee how did he have the
time amazing you see his face it looks
great broken neck after he escapes from
the bus so visually cool it looks so
well done I'm pretty sure as practical
there's a moment where Michael Myers
just full-on head stops someone just
like grounds his foot into someone's
head and it just explodes it's
incredible the most unrealistic one is
that he's completely skinned to someone
he's completely Leatherface to this
person's you know head off like the full
round thing sticks a flashlight in it
and it becomes a jack-o'-lantern
that's amazing you get a really great
callback with somebody sitting under a
sheet who's just dead but it's like you
know from the first one do you get it
tons of callback every call back was
amazing the audience I start with was so
into it we got like seven applause
breaks and a lot of laughing and you
know a couple fun people yelling things
out it was such a blast it felt like
seeing a horror film in like the early
90s which I never did but it felt like
it you got a few new care
introduced in this one the daughter and
the granddaughter are introduced as
their own thing in this you have a new
doctor Loomis has passed away in this
and you have the apprentice of Loomis
who is now the doctor of Michael minors
and he plays a pretty large role he at
one point puts on Michael Myers mask
he's really become obsessed with his
work and study of Michael Myers which is
interesting I think they took it just as
far as they could and then they let it
go he puts on the mask and I was just
like please don't go on a killing
rampage as Michael Myers please oh my
please and then they don't and then he
gets his head stomped in which is lovely
lovely to see one slight thing that I
will say that I found a little weird
is an introduction of two characters
right up top who are investigative
journalists and they have been looking
into the Michael Myers case forever and
they have all these awards for reopening
cases and then solving them and like
bringing new light to things it's kind
of hinted at that they're going to be in
the film a lot and they get killed off
fairly near the beginning of the film
and I really liked the parts they were
in and I also will say I'm glad that
they weren't a huge a bigger huger part
of the film it was just a weird thing to
kind of have them there and then knock
there but like so there in the beginning
it was it was just it was lower that
being said the opening ruled I really
liked it it got an applause break after
it was done it was it was really
effective they show up to the prison
he's at before he's transferred to the
next prison and they bring out the masks
and they have it kind of I guess so now
that I'm thinking about it it's a way
for you to be reintroduced to the mask
and for you to know how he then got it
back there's two more things that didn't
bother me but we're a little out of
place I would say one being a scene
where the gram on the daughter are not
on great terms I really like the
daughter she's a great actress she's in
a lot of things there's one scene that I
didn't love and I don't think it was her
act
ability at all I think she's really good
I think it might have been just a weird
directorial thing or script thing though
I loved the direction and everything
else that I loved the script in
everything else but there's this awkward
dinner scene and the granddaughter sees
the grandmother acting a little crazy
and the moms like I wanted to shield you
from it but that was my childhood and
then I was so sad my whole child she
goes into this whole thing she's talking
and there's like voiceover over this
weird like montage that feels like it's
a very weird shift it feels different
than anything else in the movie and then
the last thing I'll say that kind of
didn't bother me but wasn't as
satisfying as I would have loved is just
the ending it's really hard to end this
I didn't know if they were gonna like
completely kill the franchise or not
they don't the ending that we got though
was not not an extremely strong ending
for Laurie Strode more so we got a lot
of badass moments with her daughter
Karen I guess it was like oh well look
at all of that hardship and your
childhood paid off but I don't care
about that at all because she really
didn't set it up to be like this really
thing that you felt bad for her about
you we wanted that for Laurie the stuff
with the house was amazing the stuff and
fighting him at the end was amazing the
whole ending was amazing I just I don't
know it was missing one thing and I
don't know what it is I don't know what
I would have changed about it so you
know not helpful but I don't know and
then they're driving away in a car that
happens to pull up and the granddaughter
is holding the knife and she's looking
really scared and it's like well then is
she gonna be the murderer now please say
no please say no please say no I got
peanut butter on my penis it's a great
one-liner from this great not one that I
thought I would get from a slasher but
one that I'm very glad that I got from a
slasher something that I really love is
that you finally get to hear the famous
Halloween theme song and it starts right
when this extremely long shot starts and
there's some really great long shots in
the first movie another great callback
and the music goes on just as long as
the long shot goes on and the long shot
ends
music ends and it's brilliant and let me
tell you something guys I would have
never noticed that if hadn't been for
Tamra's never seen the tomato sauce so
look at me moving on up in the film
world
I find myself usually with these kind of
films pretty disappointed and I just
think they really hit most of the marks
they hit the callback so well and not a
cheesy way they hit the script oh well
and it's like it's really funny but it's
still really grounded the acting was
absolutely so so good
the deaths were amazing the suspense was
killer
I loved this I think if you find too
many problems with this film you just
can't you kind of you kind of went in
like hoping that it wasn't gonna be good
I saw the first Halloween film in high
school and I loved it
and I haven't seen it since then until
today where I released my second viewing
said a ripoff no and the video is out
this morning on my personal channel so
check that out if you want my reaction
to that thank you so much for watching I
will see you all next week
you know the jump scares and like some
peas but like had just jumped in a trash
bin so how they scared me more than a
lot of the sequels of this franchise but
we'll get into that
[Music]